there is a a full-on brawl that broke
out this is in times square
yesterday they threw like an actual
explosive in the diamond district
they went to a restaurant they started
spitting on jewish niners
and you are seeing people on the left
look the other way this is not being
covered in the mainstream media
there's something that joe biden did not
mention in his speech and that of course
is the vast wave of anti-semitic attacks
that's now hitting american cities
it's european cities as well there's a
increase in anti-semitic incidents in
the uk in the middle of the gaza war
this has happened
during many of the conflicts that have
happened in the middle east
very often people who say well it's just
anti-scientific just anti-zionism it's
just anti-israel activity it's not about
the jews
we're why are you attacking that random
jew in london very very strange
and some people say well if israel went
away there would be less anti-semitism
or
meanwhile beating a jew like good good
good idea guys like really that makes a
whole hell of a lot of sense
biden didn't mention this because the
left has a perverse perspective on
anti-semitism which is that
anti-semitism
only matters when the person committing
the anti-semitism is a white supremacist
when it turns out that anti-semitism is
a mainstream part of an increasingly
mainstream segment
of the international left then
anti-semitism has to be ignored in other
words when anti-semitism is part of a
political program a broader political
program
to for example end the jewish state or
part of a broader political program
to set up jews who are
disproportionately well-educated and
successful in western societies
as sort of the evil at the top of the
intersectional hierarchy
as beneficiaries of a system that needs
to be brought down then anti-semitism
gets ignored
which of course is why the democratic
party just last year decided that they
were not going to bother
censoring uh or censuring rather ilhan
omar
for her blatant anti-semitism instead
they decided that they were going to
pass some sort of
broad resolution condemning all bad
things on planet earth because the
reality is that the left cannot
acknowledge anti-semitism when it comes
from the left
instead they have to pretend that it
just doesn't exist and so
as we'll see there's been a bevy of
anti-semitic attacks in the united
states
over the course of the last week it is
not a coincidence that it is happening
in the middle of this conflict with
israel because the same peop
again these people are siding with hamas
okay hamas is a terrorist group
this is not about a border conflict
hamas openly states it wants israel
completely destroyed which means a
genocide of the jews
today the front page of the new york
times website has zero
articles about the uptick in
anti-semitic crime the washington post
its front page today online has zero
stories
about anti-semitism across the nation
both ran op-eds
talking about why it would be necessary
for israel to stop existing
that is not a coincidence anti-semitism
is part and parcel of the broader
international left agenda at this point
and that agenda is to tear
down any vestiges and systems that they
believe
are are implicit in the west and israel
is just
part of that right the the international
left hates israel because they really
don't like
the the traditional systems of the west
not the other way around
before we get into these anti-semitic
incidents a quick primer
on when anti-semitism is coincident with
anti-israel sentiment
hey so you can disagree with israeli
policy i often disagree with israeli
policy
i for example think that israel never
should have pulled out of the gaza strip
in 2005.
i think handing it over to hamas was a
terrible decision i think israel never
should have engaged in the oslo process
with a terrorist group known as the
palestine liberation organization
and that doesn't make me anti-semitic
and people on the other side who believe
that israel should make more concessions
that doesn't doesn't mean that you are
anti-semitic there are a few key
indicators as to when
anti-israel sentiment bleeds over into
anti-semitism one if you're siding with
an active terrorist group that is firing
indiscriminately rockets at civilians
while shielding its own weaponry with
children it's very hard to come up with
an alternative explanation for why you
think that is okay other than you don't
like jews
if you are treating the jewish state in
a way you would treat no other state if
there's a double standard okay and this
isn't my standard is the state
department standard for anti-semitism
if you treat the jewish state in a way
different than you would treat any other
state
it's an indicator of anti-semitism okay
so those are a couple indicators of when
anti-israel sentiment bleeds over
into anti-semitism and by the way if you
wish to see the full-scale destruction
of the state of israel
you don't wish to see the destruction of
any other state on planet earth right
you don't wish to see the destruction
of any islamic regime there are over 50
50 of them like 57 58 members of the
organization of islamic countries
explicitly islamic full-on apartheid
states for people of other religions
you don't care about that you don't care
about the 100 plus countries
that are christian in orientation all
you care about is the one jewish state
that looks an awful lot like an
anti-semitic double standard
and while the left has embraced that
because the left sees israel as a
repository of colonialism in the region
which has to ignore
all of human history there have been
jews in this region since 1000 bce
jewish presence in the holy land
predates the existence of islam by some
sixteen hundred years minimum
the first and second temples were built
hundreds of years
before islam even existed and so the
notion that this is some sort of
colonialist outpost of western
civilization
is a particularly bizarre one
considering how jews were often treated
throughout europe
and throughout russia and throughout
every other place throughout human
history
the the notion that the jews were sort
of like put there by the europeans in
order to bother the arabs is insane
especially considering the fact
that british mandate palestine attempted
explicitly to bar jews from buying land
for decades on end
and restricted jewish immigration that
in a way that had never restricted arab
immigration including restricting jewish
immigration from europe
during world war ii as jews were being
sent to the gas chambers in europe
and post-world war ii in order to
placate the local arab population
and so you have to just ignore all of
history to come to the conclusion
that this is a colonialist settler
outpost okay but that is exactly what
the left wants to say because this all
fits into a broader left-wing world view
the broader left-wing worldview is that
anyone who is successful in a western
system is successful because they have
somehow victimized the other
it's the same thing that you see in
america with regards to critical race
theory that
inequality of outcome is evidence of
discrimination same thing when it comes
to global politics if israel is very
successful and the palestinians are not
particularly successful that is not
because the palestinian leadership
are a bunch of terrorists who have
misdirected all funding
toward terrorism and destroyed property
rights and made it
impossible for people to start
businesses and crack down on dissent
and have destroyed democracy and
actually live in a one-party apartheid
state
no it's not because of any of that it
must be because there's this other group
that's very successful right next to
them
despite the fact that that other group
twenty percent of its population is arab
they're arabs who sit in the knesset
it's a very large part of the iran party
they're arabs who sit on the supreme
court all of this is perfectly obvious
so if you ignore all of that just
because you don't like israel at that
point you have to start looking
at the possibility that anti-semitism
lies behind this okay and
again that is why it is no coincidence
that you're seeing palestinian
anti-semitism on the streets of the
united states
and you're seeing people on the left
look the other way this is not being
covered in the mainstream media in much
the same way that the mainstream media
really didn't want to cover anti-asian
violence in the united states
until there was that mass shooting by
somebody they could label the white
supremacist in atlanta
right when that happened then they could
talk about anti-asian violence and they
could pass an anti-asian hate crime bill
but they will not pass an anti-semitic
hate crime
crackdown bill they certainly won't do
that because the people who are largely
prominent getting anti-semitism
in the united states these days are on
the political left and that is being
mainstreamed into the political left
so here are some videos these are from
new york over the last 48 hours
by the way palestinian protesters are
specifically
attempting to set up protests in jewish
areas all around the country
the reason they're doing that of course
is because they believe that these are
pro-israel centers
and so they have to get in the face of
every jew in order to in order to
demonstrate
something i'm not sure what it is they
think they are demonstrating okay this
one was really bad yesterday
there were some some i mean this is an
act of terrorism i mean
somebody went and took a small molotov
cocktail and they took it down to the
diamond district
in new york and they they threw like an
actual explosive in the diamond district
okay then they went to a restaurant
these palestinian activists
and by activism criminals they went to
because there are activists and they're
criminals if you go to a
if you go to a restaurant you start
spitting on people you start spitting on
jewish niners
you're a criminal assault you have
palestinian activists who are riding
down the street
shouting f the jews
it's good times in good times in new
york over there uh there is a a full-on
brawl that broke out when
palestinian activists decided they were
going to attack
uh jewish activists there were jewish
activists holding israeli flags
palestinian activists went and grabbed
the flag away from them
and then started to beat up the jews uh
there are a couple of uh this is in
times square so this is just
wonderful stuff by the way where are the
cops in all this
like seriously where where are the
police and we've seen this in los
angeles
we saw in los angeles that there are
jews who are eating outside of the sushi
restaurant on oceanic boulevard
and palestinian activists slash
criminals
decided that they were going to stop try
to shout at the jews get out of their
car and then go and beat up the jews
we saw a jew being chased down by a
couple of
trucks with giant palestinian flags on
the back
all this stuff is happening and the
media just have no interest in covering
the actual crimes you'll see an
occasional story about
eric garcetti in l.a for example
condemning the hate crimes
nothing yet from bill de blasio so far
as i'm aware nothing from
andrew cuomo the governor of new york
nothing from chuck schumer
the jewish senator from new york nothing
in fact from anybody in the democratic
party hierarchy
why the answer is because if they
recognize
that perhaps the people who are siding
with hamas very often are driven
well not very often if you side with
hamas not just you know like some things
israel's doing you side with hamas
this means you're an anti-semite there's
just no way to read you siding with an
actual overt evil terrorist group as
anything other than you hate the people
that the terrorists are attempting to
kill
okay and and this has mainstreamed
itself into
the into media so there's open
anti-semitism
and it exists largely at the highest
echelons of the islamic world
and particularly in islamically governed
countries like pakistan
there was a pakistani foreign minister
who just went on cnn and frankly good
for the cnn host here the cnn host
called him on it but the pakistani
foreign minister literally won a
national television and said the jews
run the media
which is which is pretty wild we'll get
to that in just one second but msnbc is
busily actually promulgating the
anti-semitism
just like members of the democratic
party are promulgating the anti-semitism
just like the washington post is
promulgating the anti-semitism now
this doesn't mean that everybody in the
democratic party higher echelon
is an anti-semite it just means they're
winking and nodding at it
i mean joe biden any time could say
something about ilhan omar and rashida
talib instead
joe biden who was fairly tolerant of
israel
performing its duty to defend its
citizens he was out there praising
rashida to leave well or she told us
being an open anti-semite supporting
actual acts of terrorism
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like
and subscribe to help keep our videos on
the front line of the fight
and top of your feed